It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在正值传粉盛季，我的业务规模迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为 35 美元/月。这可是一个不会常有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需税费和政府规费。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. For many women, the shifting hormones of midlife bring troubling physical and mental health symptoms, hot flashes, disrupted sleep, mood changes, and even memory issues. But although half the world's population will probably experience menopause, for decades it received relatively little serious attention from doctors and researchers. Instead, it's been the subject of sitcom jokes and something that women were just expected to put up with. In recent years, though, researchers have focused not. new attention on women's health and learn more about the short and long-term health effects of
Google Fi Wireless 在高网络使用期间不会遭遇数据流量降级。对许多女性而言，中年荷尔蒙的剧烈波动会带来令人困扰的身心健康症状、潮热、睡眠受阻、情绪变化甚至是记忆问题。然而，尽管世界上有一半的人口都可能会经历更年期，但在过去几十年里，它却很少受到医生和研究人员的认真关注。相反，它往往成为情景喜剧中的笑料，或是被认为女性只能逆来顺受的事情。不过，近年来，研究人员开始对女性健康给予新的关注，并深入了解了女性健康短期的以及长期的影响。
menopause. They've even found links between menopause symptoms and cardiovascular and Alzheimer's risk. So what are the major mental and physical health effects of menopause? How common are experiences like hot flashes, mood changes, and memory changes? What are the implications for women's physical, mental and cognitive health later in life? And what risks and benefits should women consider as they think about and talk to their doctors about treatments, including hormone replacement therapy. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills, coming to you today from our annual convention APA 2025 in Denver.
更年期。他们甚至发现了更年期症状与心血管及阿尔茨海默病风险之间的联系。那么，更年期对身心健康的主要影响有哪些？像潮热、情绪波动以及记忆改变这样的经历有多常见？这对女性晚年的身体、心理和认知健康意味着什么？当女性考虑治疗方案并与医生沟通（包括激素替代疗法）时，应该权衡哪些风险和收益？欢迎收听《心理学说话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），今天在丹佛我们举办的 APA 2025 年年度大会上为您进行报道。
My guest today is Dr. Rebecca Thurston, a clinical health psychologist and assistant dean for Women's Health Research and Director of the Center for Women's Biob behavioral Health Research at the University of Pittsburgh. She also holds appointments in the departments of psychiatry, epidemiology, psychology, and clinical and translational science. Dr. Thurston's research has looked at connections between menopause and cardiovascular disease and brain aging, as well as how a history of trauma affects people's experience of menopause. So, Dr. Thurston, when does menopause start for most women and how long does it typically last? For most women, the beginnings of the menopause will happen in the 40s, late 40s, maybe early 50s. And that's marked by the perimenopause,
我今天的嘉宾是丽贝卡·瑟斯顿博士（Dr. Rebecca Thurston），她是匹兹堡大学的临床健康心理学家、女性健康研究助理院长兼女性生物行为健康研究中心主任。她还在精神病学、流行病学、心理学以及临床和转化科学系担任职务。瑟斯顿博士的研究主要探讨更年期与心血管疾病及大脑老化之间的联系，以及创伤史如何影响人们的更年期体验。那么，瑟斯顿博士，更年期对大多数女性而言通常从什么时候开始，一般会持续多久？对于大多数女性来说，更年期的萌芽会发生在 40 多岁、40 岁后期，或者 50 岁出头。这以围绝经期为标志。
which is a time of menstrual cycle irregularity and skipping. And after a woman have skipped 12 months of menstrual cycles, she enters into the postmenopause where she stays the rest of her life. And the average age of the onset of postmenopause is 51. What hormonal and other changes happen to the body during menopause? There's multiple different hormonal changes. The most well-characterized hormone changes are declines in the ovarian estrogen estradial. That's our most potent estrogen in the body. And in about those plus or minus two years before and after that onset of postmenopause
这段时期月经周期不规律且经常跳过。在一位女性连续 12 个月没有来月经之后，她就进入了绝经后期，并将在此度过余生。绝经后期开始的平均年龄是 51 岁。在更年期期间，身体会发生哪些激素及其他变化？会发生多种不同的激素变化。特征最明显的激素变化是卵巢雌激素雌二醇水平的下降。这是我们体内最强效的雌激素。大约在绝经后期开始前后的那正负两年内，
is when you have the most dramatic declines in estradial. And then you have steady increases in something called follicle. stimulating hormone. That's secreted by your pituitary, trying to tell your ovary to screen estrogen-yel, the ovary says, I'm done. FSA keeps rising, trying to get that ovary to respond, and that eventually levels out at high levels. And that's the same. It's around those plus or minus two years around the onset of the postmenopause. But what's really important to keep in mind is that these hormones are bouncing around from month to month during the perimenopause. So one month will be very high, one month will be very low.
雌二醇会发生最剧烈的下降。随后，一种名为卵泡刺激素（FSH）的物质会稳步增加。这是由你的垂体分泌的，试图告诉你的卵巢分泌雌激素，而卵巢则回应说：我罢工了。FSH 不断上升，试图让卵巢做出反应，这种状况最终在高水平上趋于平稳。这同样发生在绝经后期开始前后的正负两年左右。但真正需要牢记的是，在围绝经期，这些激素在每个月之间都在上下波动。所以某个月的水平会非常高，而另一个月的水平则会非常低。
So getting a single hormone test during the perimenopause, that time of menstrual cycle irregularity and skipping, is typically not so useful. It's when you enter into the postmenopause that you really can understand from getting your hormones tested where you are. And why would a woman want to have a test? Many women want to know what's going on. They're having a lot of symptoms. Things feel a little out of control, whether it's with the symptoms. are experiencing or their menstrual cycle changes, and they want answers. They want to know what's
因此，在围绝经期（即月经周期不规律且经常间断的时期）进行单次激素检测，通常并没有太大用处。只有当你进入绝经后期后，通过激素检测，你才能真正弄清楚自己目前处于什么阶段。那么，女性为什么会想要做这项检测呢？许多女性想要了解究竟发生了什么。她们身上出现了许多症状。无论是在经历的症状还是月经周期的变化方面，一切都让人感觉有些失控，她们想要得到答案。她们想知道
happening. So it's useful to be able to tell women where you are in the menopause transition. Unfortunately, that single blood test hormone assay is not going to do it if you're in the perimenopause. Hot flashes are one of the most well-known symptoms of menopause. How common are they? Why do they happen? What is the biological mechanism that's at work? Well, I've spent decades studying hot flashes. specifically, so you come to the right place, about 70, 75% of women will experience hot flashes. They typically start during the perimenopause and continue. So they last about 7 to 10 years for moderate to severe hot flashes and longer for less severe hot flashes. And there's pronounced racial ethnic differences in hot flashes.
发生了什么。因此，能够准确告诉女性她们处于更年期过渡的哪个阶段是非常有用的。不幸的是，如果你正处于围绝经期，单次血液激素检测是无法做到这一点的。潮热是更年期最著名的症状之一。它们有多常见？为什么会发生？其背后的生物学机制是什么？嗯，我几十年来一直在专门研究潮热，所以你找对人了，大约 70% 到 75% 的女性都会经历潮热。它们通常从围绝经期开始并持续下去。中度至重度潮热大约持续 7 到 10 年，程度较轻的潮热则会持续更长时间。潮热在种族和族裔上存在显着的差异。
So upwards of 80% of black women will get hot flashes. We used to think Asian women didn't get hot flashes. That's not true. Upers the 50% of women, Asian women will get hot flashes. And the white and the Latino women, at least in our Swan study, were kind of in the middle. And for some women, they actually start when they're still menstruating in those late reproductive years. For other women, they go on and on and on well into their 60s and beyond sometimes. So if you still are having hot flashes, you're not alone.
因此，多达 80% 的黑人女性会出现潮热。我们过去认为亚洲女性不会经历潮热。事实并非如此。多达 50% 的亚洲女性、女性会出现潮热。而白人女性和拉丁裔女性，至少在我们的 SWAN 研究中，处于中间水平。对某些女性来说，潮热实际上在她们仍处于生育晚期、还在来月经时就开始了。而对另一些女性来说，潮热会一直持续到 60 多岁甚至更久。所以，如果你仍然在经历潮热，你并不孤单。
That's probably about 20% of women. It goes on for quite a long time. So the neurobiology of hot flashes, we've just recently. there's been recent breakthroughs in this. For a while, we didn't really know what caused them, and we knew it has something to do with the thermoregulatory system, and it went something like this. So our body keeps our core body temperature within a thermonutral zone. When we go above the zone, we sweat, when we go below this zone, we shiver. And those are mechanisms that our body uses to bring our core body temperature within this thermo neutral zone. However, there was some evidence,
这大概占到女性的 20% 左右。这种情况会持续相当长的一段时间。至于潮热的神经生物学，我们最近刚有了突破。有一段时间，我们并不知道是什么引发了潮热，我们只知道它与体温调节系统有关，其机制大致如下。我们的身体将核心体温维持在热中性区内。当我们高于这个区域时就会出汗，当我们低于这个区域时就会发抖。这些是身体用来将核心体温拉回热中性区的机制。然而，有一些证据表明，
early evidence in the 90s to show that these women who had a lot of hot flashes, they had a very narrowed thermo-neutral zone. And so small changes in core body temperature were experienced as much too hot. You get this massive heat dissipation event in the form of hot flash and cools you down. And then sometimes you get shivering and overshooting. So that was kind of the heuristic model, so to speak. But we didn't really understand the biology. Naomi Rance came along in the mid-aughts, and she actually helped elucidate what's the underlying neurobiology. So this is all happening in the brain and the hypothalamus. And there's these cute little neurons called these candy neurons that actually act as the relay station between the thermoregulatory centers of
90 年代的早期证据显示，那些经历大量潮热的女性，其热中性区非常狭窄。因此，核心体温的微小变化就会被体验为“太热了”。你会经历一次以潮热形式爆发的巨大散热事件，从而使体温冷却下来。有时随之而来的是寒战和过度调节。所以，这可以说是一种启发式模型。但我们当时并不真正理解其中的生物学原理。娜奥米·兰斯（Naomi Rance）在 2000 年代中期出现，她实际上帮助阐明了潜在的神经生物学机制。这一切都发生在大脑和下丘脑中。有一类非常可爱的神经元叫做亲吻素神经元（kisspeptin neurons），它们实际上充当了体温调节中枢之间的中继站。
your body and the hormonal centers, the master control of a reproductive axis, both are in the hypothalamus, and the way that they talk to each other is through these candy neurons. And we have a new class of agents that are very effective in treating hot flashes on neurokinen three receptor antagonists, neurokinine 1-3 receptor antagonists that go after that neurobiology and they very effectively treat hot flashes. Do we have any idea what purpose hot flashes serve as a woman is going through menopause? We have no idea. There's been many hypotheses, many tales told, but no, we don't really understand any kind of evolutionary benefit that hot flashes may have or even health benefit to women. In fact, we typically find
你的身体和荷尔蒙中枢、生殖轴的主控中心都位于下丘脑中，它们之间正是通过这些亲吻素神经元进行沟通的。我们现在有一类能够非常有效治疗潮热的新型药物，即神经激肽 3 受体拮抗剂（neurokinin 3 receptor antagonists）、神经激肽 1-3 受体拮抗剂，它们针对这一神经生物学机制，能非常有效地治疗潮热。我们是否知道潮热在女性经历更年期时起到什么作用？我们毫无所知。人们提出了许多假设，也流传过许多传说，但并没有，我们确实不理解潮热可能具有的任何进化益处，甚至对女性的健康益处也没有。事实上，我们通常发现的
quite the opposite. So it's not like a fever where it's trying to fight off an infection. It's just your temperature has gone a little haywire. Your thermostat has gone a little haywire. So it's like your body's internal thermostat doesn't quite know that these small changes in body temperature are not a reason to have these big heat dissipation events. That thermoutral zone getting very narrow indicates that that thermostat, a little broken, and it seems to come back online for most women when they make it through the menopause transition. What are some of the other physical and mental health challenges that women might experience
恰恰相反。所以它不像发烧那样是为了抵抗感染。它只是你的体温有点失控了。你的体温调节中枢有点失控了。所以这就好比你身体内部的恒温器根本不知道体温的这些微小变化并不构成发生这些巨额散热事件的理由。热中性区变得非常狭窄，这表明那个恒温器有点坏了，而对于大多数女性来说，当她们度过更年期过渡期后，它似乎又恢复正常运作了。女性在更年期期间可能会经历哪些其他身心健康挑战？
during menopause? So the most common symptoms, so we have our hot flashes, upwards of 70% of women, about 50% of women, if not more, experienced problems with sleep, clinically significant problems with sleep. This is a huge one. In fact, there's a two-to-threefold increase likelihood of having sleep. problems during the menopause transition relative to the premenopause when we follow women and compare them to themselves. So sleep problem is huge. We see the brain fog and memory issues,
所以最常见的症状，除了我们占女性 70% 以上的潮热之外，大约 50% 甚至更多的女性还会经历睡眠问题，即临床意义上的睡眠问题。这是一个大问题。事实上，与绝经前相比，在围绝经期出现睡眠问题的可能性增加了两到三倍，这是我们在追踪女性并将她们与自身进行对比时发现的。所以睡眠问题非常严重。我们还会看到脑雾和记忆问题，
as well as distractibility, difficulty with emotion regulation, which is sort of part of this clustering of cognitive symptoms. We also see increased risk for depression and anxiety. The Swan study actually did clinical interviews to be able to diagnose depression. We found a two-to-fourfold increased likelihood of depression, clinical depression during the menopause transition as compared to the premenopause. So that's really important. Also increases in anxiety symptoms, really common. I see this a lot clinically, in fact. And in terms of the biological side, we do see with midlife aging, waking, that's a midlife aging effect. The menopause effect is changes in body composition. So even if your weight stable, there's increases in fat,
以及注意力不集中、情绪调节困难，这些都属于认知症状群的一部分。我们还会看到抑郁和焦虑风险的增加。SWAN 研究实际上通过临床访谈来诊断抑郁症。我们发现在更年期过渡期间，患临床抑郁症的可能性与绝经前相比增加了两到四倍。所以这非常重要。同时，焦虑症状的增加也非常普遍。事实上我在临床中经常看到这一点。在生物学方面，随着中年衰老，我们确实会看到体重增加，这是一种中年衰老效应。更年期效应则是身体成分的变化。因此，即使你的体重保持稳定，脂肪也会增加，
mass decreases in bone and muscle, unfortunately. And that like that little bit of a tire you get around your waist, very common standard menopause thing. So the weight changes. We see accelerations in vascular risk, even when we image women's vessels, even controlling for age. And then also, like I mentioned, pretty marked decreases in bone mineral density. Anything on the plus side? I mean, you know, I think you're not having a monthly period anymore. You're not having those symptoms and you don't have to worry about getting pregnant during sex. So, you know, are there some good things? Yes, yes, yes. There are good things. Now, this is, unfortunately, received a lot less empirical attention than the bad things. And I forgot to mention
不幸的是，骨骼和肌肉质量却在下降。就像腰部周围长出的那一圈赘肉一样，这是非常常见且标准的更年期现象。所以会出现体重变化。我们会看到血管风险加速，即使对女性的血管进行成像，甚至在控制了年龄因素之后也是如此。并且正如我所提到的，骨矿物质密度也会出现非常显着的下降。有没有什么好的一面？我的意思是，你知道，我认为你不再有月经了。你不会再经历那些症状，在进行性行为时也不用担心怀孕。所以，你知道，有没有什么好的方面？有，有，有。确实有好的方面。现在，不幸的是，相比于不好的方面，这受到的实证关注要少得多。我刚才忘了提
the urogenital changes that come as well. So the vaginal dryness. So that's a thing. Now, on the positive side, what I see clinically, and there's some data to support this, so of course, you don't have that period anymore. You don't have to worry about pregnancy, and more. But from a psychological perspective, I see increased self-confidence, increased feelings of being yourself, not caring what people think about you quite as much. You know, people talk about that invisibility of midlife women. Sometimes that's a gift. You feel it is enhanced sense of freedom. And you just realize that, you know what, life's too short. I'm just going to be who I am and people are going to take it or leave it. And that's what I see a lot of. And I think that's
也会随之而来的泌尿生殖系统改变。比如阴道干燥。所以这也是一个问题。现在，在积极的一面，我在临床中看到的情况，并且也有一些数据支持这一点——当然，你不再有那个经期了。你不再需要担心怀孕，诸如此类。但从心理学的角度来看，我看到的是自信心的增强，自我感觉的提升，不再那么在乎别人对你的看法。你知道，人们总在谈论中年女性的“隐形感”。有时这反倒是一份礼物。你会感受到一种增强的自由感。而且你会意识到，你知道吗，生命太短暂了。我将做我自己，别人爱接受不接受。这就是我经常看到的。而且我认为这
fantastic. I take it. You've seen that woman online who does the We Don't Care Club. Yeah, I mean, she's hysterical. Love it. It's the glasses. All the glasses. Yeah, she's great. Yeah. Your research has found that more frequent or severe hot flashes are linked to early signs of heart disease in women. Can you tell us about that research? What did you find? Why would hot flashes be linked to cardiovascular risk? Well, we started asking this question because we saw that, that there was two different analyses of these big hormone therapy trials, the women's health initiative in the HERS studies. Both studies looked at the effects of hormone therapy as a prevention for cardiovascular disease, whether primary or secondary prevention. Both
太棒了。我想你一定看过网上那个制作“不在乎俱乐部”（We Don't Care Club）的女性吧？对，我的意思是，她太滑稽了。太喜欢了。就是那些眼镜。所有的眼镜。对，她太棒了。对。你的研究发现，更频繁或更严重的潮热与女性心脏病的早期迹象有关。你能给我们讲讲那项研究吗？你们发现了什么？为什么潮热会与心血管风险相关？嗯，我们开始提出这个问题是因为我们发现，在大型激素替代疗法试验（即“妇女健康倡议”（WHI）和 HERS 研究）的两次不同分析中存在这种现象。这两项研究都考察了激素替代疗法作为心血管疾病预防（无论是初级预防还是二级预防）的效果。这两项
studies showed that hormone therapy did not prevent heart disease, particularly for the older women, and may actually increase risk. Little known are several post-talk analyses of those trials that showed that the women at the greatest cardiovascular disease risk with hormone therapy, the older women in the women's health initiative, were women with hot flashes. So it made me ask, what is it about the underlying vascular that's different about these women with hot flashes? They are called vasomotor events, after all. So what role does the vasolature have? And I began by asking, is there something about the vascular endothelium that is different among women with hot flashes? and that's this single cell layer lining the vessel very important to tone in health,
研究都表明，激素替代疗法并不能预防心脏病，特别是对老年女性而言，甚至可能增加风险。鲜为人知的是，对这些试验进行的几次事后分析表明，在接受激素替代疗法、心血管疾病风险最大的女性中——即“妇女健康倡议”中的老年女性——正是那些经历潮热的女性。这让我不禁发问，这些经历潮热的女性，其潜在的血管系统有什么不同呢？毕竟它们被称为血管舒缩事件。那么血管系统发挥了什么作用？我首先提出了这样一个问题：经历潮热的女性，其血管内皮是否存在某种不同？内皮是衬于血管内壁的单细胞层，对血管的张力和健康至关重要，
vascular tone in health, and it is one of the first things to go in the atherosclerotic process, the development of cardiovascularies. You see changes relatively early in life. And indeed, our first analysis showed in one of our big cohort studies that women with hot flashes had poor endothelial function than women without hot flashes. Later, we conducted something called the Ms. Hart study, where we had women wearing objective hot flash monitors, so we get markers of their hot flashes, these wearable monitors.
血管张力和健康，它是动脉粥样硬化过程（即心血管疾病的发展）中最先受损的部位之一。你在生命的相对早期就能看到这种变化。事实上，我们的初步分析在一项大型队列研究中显示，经历潮热的女性其内皮功能比没有潮热的女性更差。后来，我们开展了一项名为 Ms. Hart 的研究，我们让女性佩戴客观的潮热监测仪，从而获得她们潮热的标志物，也就是这些可穿戴监测仪。
And indeed, among the women with hot flashes, the more they had, the greater their underlying atherosclerosis when we image their vessels. And then in our large longitudinal cohort study called Swan, we were able to ask, if you have lots of hot flashes in your 40s and 50s, what happens to your heart disease risk later in life? We actually had hard clinical events, heart attack, strokes. and we found that women with lots of hot flashes during the pari and postmenopause, particularly if they persisted for many years,
确实，在经历潮热的女性中，她们经历的次数越多，当我们对她们的血管进行成像时，其潜在的动脉粥样硬化程度就越严重。然后，在我们名为 SWAN 的大型纵向队列研究中，我们得以提出这样一个问题：如果在 40 岁和 50 岁时经历大量潮热，晚年的心脏病风险会发生什么变化？我们实际上追踪了明确的临床事件，即心脏病发作、中风。我们发现，在围绝经期和绝经后期经历大量潮热的女性，特别是如果这些潮热持续多年，
those women had a 70% in case risk of heart attacks and strokes later in life after controlling for things like smoking or obesity or blood pressure, etc. And this was not explained by your levels of estrogen in your body. Are there genetic links? So if your mother went through those consequences, of hot flashes that you might be more likely as well to perhaps be at risk of cardiovascular disease? So whether there's a genetic underpinning to hot flashes is still an active area of investigation. I don't think we have a great answer to that. However, I will tell you colloquially that women tell
在控制了吸烟、肥胖或血压等因素后，这些女性在晚年发生心脏病发作和中风的风险增加了 70%。并且这无法用你体内的雌激素水平来解释。是否存在基因联系？所以如果你的母亲经历过那些潮热的后果，你是否也更有可能面临心血管疾病的风险？因此，潮热是否存在基因基础仍然是一个正在积极研究的领域。我认为我们还没有一个完美的答案。不过，我可以从日常经验的角度告诉你，女性总是
me all the time that their hot flashes are similar to their mothers, their mother had lots of hot flashes, they have lots of hot flashes. Now, how that plays in the intergenerational sort of clustering of cardiovascular disease, that part we still don't know. You've also found connections between hot flashes and increased risk of Alzheimer's disease. Can you walk us through that research? Sure. So it's an interesting story. So as I was doing the work around hot flashes and cardiovascular disease, my dear friend and colleague, Pauline Mackey, was showing that visa motor symptoms or hot flashes were associated with poor cognition. So one of the major
告诉我，她们的潮热情况与母亲相似，她们的母亲经历过很多潮热，她们自己也经历了很多潮热。至于这如何在心血管疾病的代际聚集现象中发挥作用，这一部分我们仍然未知。你们还发现了潮热与阿尔茨海默病风险增加之间的联系。你能带我们了解一下这项研究吗？当然。这是一个有趣的故事。正当我围绕潮热和心血管疾病开展工作时，我亲爱的朋友兼同事保利娜·麦基（Pauline Maki）发现，血管舒缩症状或潮热与认知能力下降有关。因此，女性在更年期过渡期间经历的主要
things that happens to women during the menopause transition, they talk to me about it all the time, women started having cognitive symptoms. They're feeling brain fog. They're feeling fuzzy. They're having a harder time remembering why they walked into the room. What's that word? I can't remember. You know, it's very common. And when you measure women using objective neuropsychological tests, you see declines in what we call verbal memory performance during the menopause transition. That's memory for words on verbal material. She was showing that the women with the poorest verbal memory performance during the menopause transition were women who had lots of overnight hot flashes, objectively measured overnight hot flashes, went from these monitors.
事情之一——她们经常跟我谈起这个——就是女性开始出现认知症状。她们感到脑雾。她们感到思维模糊。她们更难记起自己为什么走进了这个房间。那个词是什么来着？我想不起来了。你知道，这非常普遍。当你使用客观的神经心理学测试来评估女性时，你会发现在更年期过渡期间，我们称之为言语记忆表现的能力会出现下降。也就是对语言材料中词语的记忆。她展示的是，在更年期过渡期间，言语记忆表现最差的女性正是那些夜间经历大量潮热的女性，即通过这些监测仪客观测得的夜间潮热。
And I was showing that women with lots of hot flashes had poor cardiovascular health. And so we teamed up and we established the Ms. Brain Study. And this is a study that looked at whether hot flashes, objectively measured hot flashes, were associated with poor brain health. And indeed, what we found is that women with a lot of hot flashes, particularly overnight, these women had greater white matter hyperintensities in their brain. So cerebrovascular risk, stroke risk, markers in their brain that indicates cerebral small vessel disease.
而我则表明，经历大量潮热的女性其心血管健康状况较差。因此，我们联合起来建立了“Ms. 大脑研究”（Ms. Brain Study）。这项研究旨在探讨潮热（即客观测得的潮热）是否与大脑健康状况不佳有关。事实上，我们发现经历大量潮热（尤其是夜间潮热）的女性，其大脑中的白质高信号更多。因此，这表明存在脑血管风险、中风风险，大脑中的这些标志物暗示了脑小血管病。
We also found that women with more sleep hot flashes had lower a beta 424. That is a blood circulating marker of aneloid, which is important to the pathophysiology of Alzheimer's disease. The women didn't have, they don't have clinical Alzheimer's disease. These are women typically in their 50s, but it's a marker of increased risk for Alzheimer's disease later in life. And this was not explained by hormones, levels. It was not explained by sleep, by mood, or any other risk factor that we could think of. We're going to take a short break. When we return, we'll talk with Dr. Thurston about the treatments available for menopause symptoms,
我们还发现，睡眠中潮热更多的女性，其血液循环中的淀粉样蛋白标志物 Aβ42/40 较低，这对阿尔茨海默病的病理生理学非常重要。这些女性并没有患上临床上的阿尔茨海默病。她们通常是 50 多岁的女性，但这是晚年患阿尔茨海默病风险增加的一个标志。这无法用激素水平来解释。它也无法用睡眠、情绪或我们能想到的任何其他风险因素来解释。我们将进行短暂的休息。休息过后，我们将与瑟斯顿博士探讨治疗更年期症状的可用方法，
including hormone replacement therapy, new medications, and behavioral interventions. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199, and entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. Lost supplies last. Price is invalid May 14th through May 27. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
包括激素替代疗法、新药物以及行为干预。家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销让你的夏日即刻启程。是时候用 Next Grill 四燃烧器燃气烤架开启夏日烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元；整个季节都可以用汉普顿湾（Hampton Bay）韦斯特格罗夫（West Grove）七件套户外餐饮桌椅招待亲友，仅需 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝尽享低价保证。售完即止。价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请访问 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路而已。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get this day you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton, for the stay. What about treatment? Let's talk about treatment for a minute. What are the treatments that are available? I mean, hormone replacement therapy has a long and complicated history. It swung back and forth between being recommended for almost everyone and then being shunned for contributing to
我们省了多少钱？够了。够多到迷路了。或者你也可以预订希尔顿（Hilton）的酒店。欢迎来到你的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿特惠正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得你所期待的住宿体验。当你想要的是节省，而不是惊吓。住哪里很关键。希尔顿，因驻留而精彩。那治疗呢？我们来谈谈治疗。有哪些可用的治疗方法？我的意思是，激素替代疗法有着漫长而复杂的历史。它在“被推荐给几乎所有人”和“因导致癌症风险增加而被摒弃”之间反复摇摆。那么现在的研究进展如何呢？
increased cancer risk. So where's the research now? So the history of hormone therapy is really interesting. And the pendulum. And the pendulum has just kept swinging on this one. So way back in the 90s, 80s and 90s, we started to see hormone therapy as kind of like the panacea for all that algae. We thought that it could do everything, whether it was make your skin look better, hair loss, weight maintenance, prevention of heart disease, prevention dementia, treat your hot flashes, help your bones, all the things. No one medication can do all those things. And what we learn from big studies like the Women's Health Initiative, for example, that looked at whether homotherapy can be used for disease
因此，激素替代疗法的历史非常有趣。而且这个天平。这个天平一直在摇摆不定。早在 90 年代、80 年代和 90 年代，我们开始将激素替代疗法视为包治百病的灵丹妙药。我们认为它无所不能，无论是让皮肤看起来更好、防止脱发、维持体重、预防心脏病、预防痴呆、治疗潮热、强健骨骼，所有这些。没有任何一种药物能做到所有这些事情。我们从像“妇女健康倡议”这样的大型研究中了解到，例如，该研究探讨了激素替代疗法是否可以用于疾病
prevention, things like cardiovascular disease or bone loss or dementia prevention. And the bottom line was that hormone therapy was not necessarily effective for preventing things like heart disease or dementia. And in fact, for women who began hormone therapy when they were a bit older in their 60s, it may actually increase your risk. For heart disease and possibly stroke and dementia. Now, this was not necessarily everybody, and hormone therapy is still a very useful tool for the management of menopausal symptoms, like hot flashes. We also found that women, or that study also found, that women who used hormone therapy were randomized to hormone therapy had less bone boss during the menopause transition. So there's really this kind of
预防，比如心血管疾病、骨质流失或痴呆预防。结论是，激素替代疗法不一定能有效预防心脏病或痴呆等疾病。事实上，对于在 60 多岁稍晚一些开始使用激素替代疗法的女性来说，它实际上可能会增加你的风险。患心脏病以及可能的中风和痴呆的风险。当然，这并不一定适用于所有人，而且激素替代疗法仍然是控制更年期症状（如潮热）非常有用的工具。我们还发现，女性——或者那项研究也发现，使用激素替代疗法、被随机分配到激素替代疗法的女性在更年期过渡期间的骨质流失更少。所以这实际上是一种
risk-benefit equation that we need to be thinking about when we're thinking about hormone therapy. We also found the hormone therapy trial was stopped because of increased breast cancer risk. So that can be an issue for some women. So again, balancing risks and benefits. We typically don't recommend hormone therapy for primary disease prevention for things like heart disease or dementia. However, very effective for the management of menopausal symptoms, provided that you don't have contraindications. And that is very important to talk to your health care provider to really tailor whether hormone therapy is right for you, as well as what kind of formulation you should be taking. There's a whole different ways to take hormone therapy, and that is something to really
我们在考虑激素替代疗法时需要权衡的风险效益方程。我们还发现，由于乳腺癌风险增加，激素替代疗法试验被叫停了。所以这对某些女性来说可能是一个问题。因此，再次强调，需要平衡风险与效益。我们通常不建议将激素替代疗法用于心血管疾病或痴呆等疾病的初级预防。然而，如果没有禁忌症的话，它对于控制更年期症状非常有效。与你的医疗服务提供者进行充分沟通非常重要，以便真正量身定制激素替代疗法是否适合你，以及你应该服用哪种剂型。有各种不同的方式来服用激素替代疗法，这确实需要与提供者共同制定。但激素替代疗法并不是我们工具箱里唯一的工具。
work with a provider around. But hormone therapy is not the only tool in our toolbox. So we also have this new class of drugs called NK3 receptor antagonist, Vizoa is one of these, otherwise known as Fezolinantant. That is from that neurobiology that I talked about. That is a non-hormonal medication. It is also FDA approved for the management of hot flashes. Other drugs that are FDA approved for hot flashes, the only other wine is paxil, essentially, peroxatine. But SSRIs and SNRIs are also used in an off-label fashion. They're not quite as effective as these other medications, but they're oftentimes used, as is gabapentin and some other non-hormonals. Now, that's hot flashes, right? That's only one of our menopausal symptoms. And if there's any
所以我们还有一类名为 NK3 受体拮抗剂的新型药物，VEOZAH 就是其中之一，也就是非索利奈坦（fezolinetant）。这源于我刚才谈到的神经生物学。这是一种非激素药物。它也获得了 FDA 批准用于治疗潮热。其他获得 FDA 批准用于治疗潮热的药物，唯一的另一种主要是帕罗西汀（Paxil），即盐酸帕罗西汀。但 SSRI（选择性 5-羟色胺再摄取抑制剂）和 SNRI（5-羟色胺和去甲肾上腺素再摄取抑制剂）也常用于适应证外（off-label）使用。它们的疗效不如其他这些药物，但经常被使用，加巴喷丁和其他一些非激素药物也是如此。现在，这是潮热，对吧？这只是我们的更年期症状之一。如果这次访谈能给你留下任何
message that you take home from this is that if you're trying to seek treatment for your menopausal symptoms, the treatment needs to be tailored to the specific symptom you're having. So if it's hot flashes, if it's sleep problems, if it's weight, one drug or one pharmacologic approach is not going to do everything. Now, we can't forget about our behavioral approaches, too. So for sleep, cognitive behavioral therapy for insomnia has been shown to be effective for sleep problems during the menopause transition. Cognitive behavioral therapy for the management of menopausal symptoms can help manage those vasomotor symptoms that won't necessarily make them go away, but can help you cope with them. And then we don't, when we look at women's brain fog, we tend to first look at their sleep and their mood to make sure we treat those things first.
启示的话，那就是如果你试图为你的更年期症状寻求治疗，治疗必须针对你所经历的具体症状进行量身定制。因此，如果是潮热、如果是睡眠问题、如果是体重，单一的药物或单一的药理学方法是无法解决所有问题的。现在，我们也不能忽视我们的行为干预方法。因此，对于睡眠而言，针对失眠的认知行为疗法已被证明对更年期过渡期的睡眠问题有效。用于控制更年期症状的认知行为疗法可以帮助控制那些血管舒缩症状，虽然不一定能让它们完全消失，但可以帮你应对它们。当我们面对女性的脑雾时，我们倾向于首先关注她们的睡眠和情绪，以确保首先治疗这些问题。
And then the mood symptoms, whether it's depression or anxiety, many of our standard psychotherapies are still what we would recommend on the behavioral side, whether it's CBT, IPT, mindfulness-based therapies, etc. You've looked at how women's life experiences, especially sexual abuse or trauma, can shape how they experience menopause. Can you talk about that work? Absolutely. So this just really sprung up from our menopause studies. that we just kept noticing that things looked a little different among these women who had trauma histories. And what we found, whether it's child abuse or adult trauma exposure, that these women had more vaso motor symptoms. So we started this with a swan study, and we found that women with a history of child abuse or neglect had an odds ratio of 1.8.
至于情绪症状，无论是抑郁还是焦虑，我们的许多标准心理疗法仍然是我们在行为方面会推荐的，无论是 CBT（认知行为疗法）、IPT（人际心理疗法）、基于正念的疗法等。你探讨了女性的生活经历，尤其是性虐待或创伤，如何塑造她们的更年期体验。你能谈谈那项工作吗？当然。这实际上是由我们的更年期研究引发的。我们不断注意到，那些有创伤史的女性情况看起来有些不同。我们发现，无论是童年虐待还是成年创伤经历，这些女性都会出现更多的血管舒缩症状。所以我们从 SWAN 研究开始着手，发现有童年虐待或忽视史的女性的优势比（odds ratio）为 1.8。
So in 1.8fold increased likelihood of having hot flashes or night sweats during the menopause transition. Later in our Ms. Hart studies where we actually had measured these hot flashes objectively, we also found that the women with a history of childhood abuse, these women had more objectively assessed hot flashes, particularly nocturnally. So that was really interesting. And then my junior faculty member working with me, Karen Jakubowski, has shown that women with trauma histories, whether it's adult or childhood, have an increased likelihood of persistent sleep problems over the course of menopause transition. So more symptoms. So we have more vaso motor symptoms, more sleep problems. And we also show that women with a history of trauma have an increased likelihood of cardiovascular
也就是说，在更年期过渡期间，出现潮热或夜间盗汗的可能性增加了 1.8 倍。后来在我们的 Ms. Hart 研究中，我们实际客观地测量了这些潮热，我们还发现有童年虐待史的女性，她们客观评估的潮热更多，尤其是在夜间。所以这非常有趣。接着，与我合作的青年教师卡伦·雅库博斯基（Karen Jakubowski）表明，有创伤史的女性（无论是成年期还是童年期），在更年期过渡期间持续出现睡眠问题的可能性增加。因此症状更多。所以我们有更多的血管舒缩症状、更多的睡眠问题。我们还表明，有创伤史的女性患心血管疾病的可能性增加。
disease. So accelerations in their underlying vascular risk over the menopause transition, when we measure their vessels using ultrasound, we see this accumulation of plaque, particularly among the women with a sexual assault history. We find that women with a workplace sexual harassment history have the doubling of the odds of hypertension, and women with a history of intimate partner violence have the doubling on the likelihood of heart attacks and strokes later in life. And that was driven by emotional intimate partner violence, not physical intimate partner violence, because we didn't have a lot of women who had physical intimate partner violence in that study. So even that non-contact sexual and interpersonal violence has implications
因此，随着更年期过渡期间潜在血管风险的加速，当我们使用超声波测量她们的血管时，我们看到了斑块的积聚，特别是在有性侵史的女性中。我们发现有职场性骚扰史的女性患高血压的几率翻倍，而有亲密伴侣暴力史的女性在晚年患心脏病发作和中风的可能性翻了一番。这是由情感上的亲密伴侣暴力驱动的，而不是身体上的亲密伴侣暴力，因为在那项研究中我们没有很多遭受身体亲密伴侣暴力的女性。因此，即使是那种无接触的性和人际暴力也对心脏产生影响。最后，我们发现有性侵史的女性大脑中的白质高信号更多。
for the heart. And then finally, we found that women with the history of sexual assault had more white matter hyperintensities in the brain. So that's that marker of cerebral small vessel disease in your brain that places you at risk for dementia and stroke later in life. But all of this is correlational, right? I mean, we don't really know an underlying cause, whether it's like a lifetime of anxiety or underlying anxiety because of what had happened to you when you were younger or is happening to you chronically. The mechanisms are probably multiple. So you probably have those classic stress pathways, whether it's activation of the HPA axis, or the autonomic nervous system.
所以这是你大脑中脑小血管病的标志物，会让你在晚年面临痴呆和中风的风险。但所有这些都是相关性的，对吧？我的意思是，我们并不真正知道潜在的原因，究竟是一生的焦虑，还是由于你年轻时发生在你身上或长期发生在你身上的事情而导致的潜在焦虑。机制可能是多方面的。所以你可能拥有那些经典的应激通路，无论是 HPA 轴的激活，还是自主神经系统的激活。事实上，这是我们发现的另一个额外情况，
Actually, that's one additional thing we found, is that women who had a history of trauma, whether it's childhood abuse or adult trauma exposure, those women had lower high-frequency heart rate variability during wake and particularly during sleep. And that's a marker of autonomic dysregulation. And that's one way that you can get from that exposure to stress to cardiovascular disease.
即有创伤史的女性（无论是童年虐待还是成年创伤经历），她们在清醒时、尤其是睡眠时的代表高频心率变异性（heart rate variability）较低。这是自主神经失调的一个标志物。这是你从压力暴露发展为心血管疾病的途径之一。
And in the case of the intimate partner violence finding, that was explained by the elevated hypertension risk among women with that intimate partner violence history. So there's probably multiple different ways that you can get here, and they all interact over the life course. Well, taking a step back, how much does all this affect women's mental health in midlife? I mean, is this generally less happy time of life, or is it a happier time of life, do we know? It really depends on the woman, right? So for some women, so that depression risk that I talked about earlier, so that two to fourfold increased risk of a major depressive episode during the menopause transition that Swan found,
就亲密伴侣暴力的发现而言，这可以通过有亲密伴侣暴力史的女性血压升高风险来解释。所以有许多不同的途径可以导致这一结果，它们在整个生命历程中相互作用。那么，退一步讲，这一切对女性中年时期的心理健康有多大影响？我的意思是，这普遍是一个不太快乐的人生阶段，还是一个更快乐的人生阶段，我们知道吗？这真的取决于具体的女性，对吧？所以对某些女性来说——也就是我之前谈到的抑郁风险，即 SWAN 研究发现的在更年期过渡期间发生重度抑郁发作的风险增加两到四倍，
the women at greatest risk were the ones who had a depression history in the past. Our first onset depressive episode is typically late adolescence early adulthood, right? And then you go on to have recurrent episodes throughout life. And menopause is a time of vulnerability to a recurrent episode. There were a subset of women, however, in Swan, that they had their first. onset depressive episode during menopause. They had never had one before. It was about 28% of the women who did not have a history. Those women were the ones with some health problems going on, anxiety, more vasimotor symptoms, and importantly, few close friends. Not married, few close friends.
风险最大的女性是那些过去有抑郁史的女性。我们首次发作的抑郁症通常在青春期后期成年初期，对吧？然后你在人的一生中继续经历复发。而更年期是一个容易发生复发的脆弱时期。然而，在 SWAN 中有一小部分女性，她们在更年期首次发作抑郁症。她们以前从未有过。大约 28% 没有病史的女性属于这种情况。这些女性是那些正经历某些健康问题、焦虑、更多血管舒缩症状，以及重要的是，知心朋友很少的女性。未婚，知心朋友很少。
That came up again and again and again in the Swan Data. The important role that those friendships in your life can play to buffer against declines in mental health during midlife. Hormones did not predict. So that's for depression. Anxiety, I see a lot of this. I see a lot of rumination, a lot of anxiety. We're living in the age of anxiety. And indeed, the anxiety date is not as strong in terms of our longitudinal studies, but there
这在 SWAN 数据中一次又一次地出现。生命中的这些友谊可以发挥重要作用，以缓冲中年时期心理健康水平的下降。激素并不能进行预测。所以这是关于抑郁的。至于焦虑，我看到了很多这种情况。我看到了很多反刍思维、很多焦虑。我们生活在焦虑的时代。事实上，就我们的纵向研究而言，焦虑的数据没有那么强，但
is probably a 1.7-fold increased odds of having it elevated anxiety during the menopause, particularly if you have lots of vasimotor symptoms, but, you know, those are older data. So I think we're in a different era now where anxiety is more prominent. And then we don't have a lot of data on other things, like bipolar disorder or some increased risk for psychotic disorders. I pay attention to women's substance use, so a lot of people are trying to use various substances to help them manage this turbulent time, whether it's more alcohol, to try to get yourself to sleep, which ultimately backfires, or your doc has put you on benzos and then a
在更年期期间，患严重焦虑的可能性大概增加了 1.7 倍，特别是如果你有很多血管舒缩症状的话，但是，你知道，那是较早的数据。所以我认为我们现在处于一个不同的时代，焦虑更为突出。然后我们没有很多关于其他情况的数据，比如双相情感障碍或精神 psychotic 疾病风险的增加。我关注女性的物质使用，所以许多人试图使用各种物质来帮助自己度过这个动荡的时期，无论是喝更多的酒来让自己入睡（这最终适得其反），还是你的医生给你服用了苯二氮卓类药物然后又用了兴奋剂。我看到女性服用的东西五花八门，最终可能会产生适得其反的效果。因此，非常注意你的物质使用是很重要的。然后我们看到很多人使用大麻来控制更年期症状。关于这是否有效，并没有太多极佳的数据。好吧，这只是当我们谈论精神病理学时的情况。但这种关于女性幸福感的总体感觉。这是一种不同的事情，对吧？这是一种感觉，你只是觉得一切都好吗？一项研究发现，大约 63% 的女性报告说，她们在更年期期间只是觉得不太像自己了。所以这是一个人们感觉状态有点不对劲的时期。然而，与此同时，人们有一种越来越不在乎别人看法的心理。
stimulant. I see a lot of mixture of things that women are taking, and ultimately it can really backfire. So being really careful about your substance use is important. And then we see a lot of cannabis for the management of metapolesal symptoms. There's not a lot of great data on whether that's efficacious or not. Now, so that's just when we talk about psychopathology. But this general sense of women's well-being. It's kind of a different thing, right? It's a sense of, do you just feel okay? One study found that about 63% of women reported that they just didn't quite feel like themselves during menopause. So is a time of people feeling just kind of off. However, at the same time, there's this increased sense of not caring, what people think,
兴奋剂。我看到女性服用的东西五花八门，最终可能会适得其反。因此，谨慎对待物质的使用非常重要。接着，我们看到很多人使用大麻来控制更年期症状。目前并没有太多确凿的数据表明其是否有效。好了，这只是当我们谈论精神病理学时的情况。但这种对女性整体福祉的普遍感受。这其实是另一回事，对吧？这是一种感觉，你是否觉得一切都好？一项研究发现，大约 63% 的女性表示，在更年期期间，她们觉得自己有点不像是自己了。所以这是一个人们会感到状态不对劲的时期。然而，与此同时，人们有一种越来越不在乎别人怎么想的感觉，
increased authenticity, potentially a feeling of self-confidence and feeling more comfortable on your own skin, maybe, not everybody, but we do see that. And so I think as clinicians, our job is to help treat the negative sides and really build upon these strengths, this sort of deepening wisdom, this sense of, yeah, you know who you are and you know what you want, a little bit more. Those things are really important aspects of midlife developmental maturation and aging that I think are great. You mentioned substance use, but I'm also wondering there a lot of women who for many years, like perhaps their whole adult lifetime, have taken birth control pills. Any research into the impact of that on menopause? So birth control pills are essentially
真实感的增加，潜在的自信感以及对自己更加舒适的感觉，也许吧，并非对每个人都如此，但我们确实看到了这一点。因此，我认为作为临床医生，我们的工作是帮助治疗消极的一面，并真正建立在这些优势之上，这种加深的智慧，这种对“是的，你知道你是谁，你知道你想要什么”的感觉的理解更加深入一些。这些是中年发育成熟和衰老的重要方面，我认为它们非常棒。你提到了物质使用，但我也在想，许多女性多年来，也许是整个成年生活，一直在服用避孕药。关于这对外年期影响的研究有哪些？所以避孕药本质上是
the same hormones, for the most part, that's in hormone therapy. Hormone therapy is just a lower dose. So some women will stay on their oral contraceptives or the birth control pills over the course of the perimenopause. But ultimately, that dose probably needs to be adjusted. So you need to talk to your doctor about where you are in the transition and when to revisit mixing up that hormone regimen as you age. So just to close, what are you working on now? What are the big questions you're still trying to answer? Oh, there's so many. I mean, we have some great data on menopause for sure from our large longitudinal studies like Swan and others. However, there's so many more questions to be answered. I mean, I just named a bunch of
激素疗法中绝大部分相同的激素。激素疗法只是剂量较低。因此，一些女性会在围绝经期期间继续服用口服避孕药或避孕药。但最终，这个剂量可能需要调整。因此，你需要和你的医生谈谈你处于转变的哪个阶段，以及随着年龄的增长，何时重新审视和调整激素方案。那么最后，你现在在研究什么？你仍在努力回答的重大问题是什么？哦，太多了。我的意思是，我们确实有一些关于更年期的大型纵向研究的绝佳数据，比如Swan和其他研究。然而，还有更多问题需要解答。我的意思是，我刚刚列举了一堆
of things we don't know about increased risk for various types of psychological problems during menopause, whether it's anxiety or PTSD or substance use disorders or things like that, that we absolutely have to know. I'm very interested in these positive aspects and how do we do some really good empirical work around really understanding the role of menopause and midlife aging in women's psychological development and they're feeling more positively about the world and about themselves. We need more interventions for helping women manage the menopause transition. Right now, so many women are kind of told and in this struggle, hormone therapy, yes, no. And menopause care is way more than hormone therapy. There's a huge, there's a wider range
我们不知道的事情，关于更年期期间各种心理问题风险增加的情况，无论是焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）还是物质使用障碍等，这些都是我们绝对必须知道的。我非常对这些积极方面感兴趣，以及我们如何围绕真正理解更年期和中年衰老在女性心理发展中的作用开展一些真正好的实证工作，她们对世界和自己有了更积极的看法。我们需要更多的干预措施来帮助女性度过更年期过渡期。现在，很多女性都被告知并处于这种挣扎中：激素疗法，要还是不要。更年期护理远不止激素疗法。有一个巨大的、更广泛的
of tools in the toolbox that we have, and women deserve more, whether they're pharmacologic approaches, behavioral approaches, or both, and this is where we really need more research. Well, Dr. Thurston, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's really a lot of good information for our listeners. Thank you so much. This has been great. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for a few episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
我们拥有的工具箱中的工具种类，女性值得拥有更多，无论是药物疗法、行为疗法还是两者兼而有之，这正是我们真正需要更多研究的地方。瑟斯顿博士，我想感谢您今天能来。这对我们的听众来说确实有很多很好的信息。非常感谢您。这太棒了。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上或在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学对话》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对某些节目有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。
Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学对话》由李·温厄曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。感谢您收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。